Julie Stout: Okay, I think we are recording. Hello, my name is Julie Stout. Today is March 20th, 2026, around 3… 3.23 p.m. Eastern Daylight Time. I am currently in Bloomington, Indiana, and I am here with…
Thomas Adler: Thomas Adler.
Thomas Adler: Thomas A, formerly.
Thomas Adler: And, I am here at home in Lexington, Kentucky.
Thomas Adler: And, I don't know.
Julie Stout: for joining me!
Thomas Adler: recording file name… I'm still Thomas Ed.
Julie Stout: You're still Thomas Adler! Yes, thank you so much for joining me. We are here for part one of our interview, where we're gonna go over your life story, your background, and everything with that. And if you're all good to go, I can start with the questions.
Thomas Adler: Sure.
Julie Stout: Awesome! How old are you today, and what is your date of birth?
Thomas Adler: My date of birth is March 31st, 1947, so it means in another little over a week, I'll be 79 years old.
Thomas Adler: So March 31st, 1947. So I'm almost 79.
Julie Stout: Your birthday's coming up so soon!
Thomas Adler: Very soon, very soon. I was, as my mother and father used to say, I was very close to being an April Fool.
Julie Stout: Oh, cause April 1st, yes.
Thomas Adler: Cool.
Julie Stout: I love that.
Julie Stout: Yo.
Thomas Adler: Where was I born? I was born in the city of Chicago, in Illinois, in the USA.
Thomas Adler: And, you want to know about my family life and childhood, parents, guardians, occupations, siblings, cultural or linguistic traditions at home.
Thomas Adler: And, that can be a long story. Now, I… I don't know if you've looked at it or not, but I… I mentioned to you in writing that I have a…
Thomas Adler: very self-indulgent website. I don't know if you've looked at it or not, but that has a good deal of background on me.
Thomas Adler: a VITA information about my parents and my brothers, but just to recap that in generalities.
Julie Stout: And you're able to go as in-depth as you want to as well, so…
Thomas Adler: Okay, well.
Julie Stout: Yeah, go ahead.
Thomas Adler: I won't… again, I could go on for many minutes, or hours even. My parents, I'll start with my parents,
Thomas Adler: My parents were both Viennese refugees.
Thomas Adler: who came to this country, they were not… I wouldn't call them Holocaust survivors, because they… they weren't,
Thomas Adler: you know, they didn't get directly persecuted or directly mistreated by the Nazis.
Thomas Adler: And in fact.
Thomas Adler: They were both physicians, both trained at the University of Vienna, but they did not know each other
Thomas Adler: Until they came to this country.
Thomas Adler: And there's more of this story, again, or at least a little bit more, or pointers to it, on my website.
Thomas Adler: the… the short… story would be that my father
Thomas Adler: Was a physician, and he and his… both his parents,
Thomas Adler: came… they got out of Austria first.
Thomas Adler: And first came to New York, and then… the,
Thomas Adler: Though he had been practicing medicine in Austria, For several years,
Thomas Adler: even with a, you know, full license in Europe, you could not practice medicine in this country without going through an internship first. So, he had to do an internship all over again. So…
Thomas Adler: He was directed to, the… To the…
Thomas Adler: University Hospital, I guess it was, in Madison, Wisconsin, and spent a year there.
Thomas Adler: I think, at that point, his parents were in New York, where there were some distant relatives or contacts. So he spent a year in Madison, Wisconsin, and then the public health service, or National Health Service, whatever it was.
Thomas Adler: said, well, Dr. Adler, are you willing to, you know, to serve
Thomas Adler: An underserved, a medically underserved area.
Thomas Adler: In the country, because he had no other connections, really, and, you know, he was… once he had completed that.
Thomas Adler: internship, he was ready to go, and he said, sure, so they sent him to Frenchburg, Kentucky, which was the county seat of Menifee County, Kentucky, in the hills of eastern Kentucky.
Thomas Adler: And there had been one previous physician there who was old and retiring, and a couple old guys that people called Doc who had no medical degrees whatsoever. So my father was, in effect, the first real medical doctor
Thomas Adler: to be practicing there. They made him the public health officer.
Thomas Adler: And, he was only allowed to practice under the supervision of the public health officer himself. Namely, practice under his own supervision. So, meanwhile, my mother,
Thomas Adler: She had one younger sister who,
Thomas Adler: My mother… my father, I should point out,
Thomas Adler: from a religious point of view, his… his mother was Catholic, his father was Jewish, they… they were not particularly religious,
Thomas Adler: But, you know, again, with that half-Jewish background, that was part of the reason they knew they needed to get out. And…
Thomas Adler: On the other hand, my mother and her family were Jews, and they knew that things were threatening. My mother was in a later class at the University of Vienna.
Thomas Adler: And she was in the… what would have been the final
Thomas Adler: year of her medical training at the University of Vienna, and she always joked that she didn't look particularly Jewish. She'd point at her nose and say, I didn't… didn't look Jewish.
Thomas Adler: But in her last year.
Thomas Adler: basically, the Nazis said, oh, you're Jewish, her maiden name was Blau, which is blue in German.
Thomas Adler: Alice Blau.
Thomas Adler: And they said, oh, Miss Blau?
Thomas Adler: You can't be here anymore.
Thomas Adler: And she was lucky at that, because some of her classmates were killed.
Thomas Adler: But… but they sim… they simply…
Thomas Adler: threw her out before she finished her medical degree. And she was faced with a decision. Her younger sister had already left, gone to Scotland, and was working in a kind of allied healthcare field. She wasn't a medical professional.
Thomas Adler: So, my mom…
Thomas Adler: thought that, you know, without finishing her degree, she could go on to England or Scotland and perhaps become a midwife, but instead, she opted to go to Switzerland, which was still free.
Thomas Adler: And she was able to matriculate at the University of Lausanne in Switzerland, and took her last year of medical school over again.
Thomas Adler: in French, not her native language.
Thomas Adler: And… finished, so I have a copy of her medical diploma, which of course is in French.
Julie Stout: Did she speak French?
Thomas Adler: Well, she had learned it as a student, you know.
Julie Stout: a student anyways. Okay, I thought she didn't know French at all, and she.
Thomas Adler: Oh, well, she knew enough.
Thomas Adler: Was diligent, you know?
Julie Stout: Yeah, yeah, of course.
Thomas Adler: So, she finished up her medical education in… at the University of Lausanne in Switzerland, and So, then…
Thomas Adler: You know, as things got worse, then she…
Thomas Adler: you know, I don't know all the details, but she found a sponsor in America
Thomas Adler: And who helped her get to the United States. It was a woman in Chicago, I believe, who later came to Cincinnati. And so mom eventually got to Chicago.
Thomas Adler: And then decided, you know, so she had a medical degree, she had to work also as an intern for a while, decided she wanted to pursue a residency in pediatrics, so she spent at least a year at the University of Iowa, at Iowa City.
Thomas Adler: And this is all before she ever met my father. And so…
Thomas Adler: there were my parents' two medical professional refugees, Holocaust refugees, I would say refugees rather than survivors, and
Thomas Adler: So… It's… at some point, she…
Thomas Adler: rendezvoused with the person who had, I believe, the person who had sponsored her to come to America, who by then was in Cincinnati. And whether it was that person or someone else said, oh, Dr. Blau, you're a Viennese doctor, I know this other Viennese doctor!
Thomas Adler: Dr. Adler, who was in Frenchburg, and somehow put them together, and there was a blind date.
Thomas Adler: And they hit it off.
Thomas Adler: And in 1943, they married.
Thomas Adler: So, that's… that's the basic story of my parents.
Julie Stout: To clarify, your dad was in Wisconsin while your mom was in Iowa, or what was that timing?
Thomas Adler: That was… I think he was in Wisconsin before she even got to.
Julie Stout: owed to the U.S.
Thomas Adler: Yeah.
Julie Stout: Oh, okay.
Thomas Adler: and then he got to Frenchburg, and then while he started in Frenchburg, she was arriving in… first in Chicago, and then in Iowa.
Julie Stout: Okay, so where did they meet, officially?
Thomas Adler: They actually met when she was visiting her sponsor in Cincinnati, and somebody said, I know this other Viennese doctor.
Thomas Adler: And that would have been in 1943.
Julie Stout: And they met in Cincinnati?
Thomas Adler: I don't know if they actually met there, if they, you know, the physical meeting, I don't know.
Julie Stout: Yeah.
Thomas Adler: If he came to Cincinnati, or how…
Julie Stout: Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Thomas Adler: But they hit it off. They both… they were both Viennese, they were both physicians, and they hit it off. And by then, of course, he was a general practitioner, she was a pediatrician, and of course, they both were familiar with Vienna.
Thomas Adler: and my father, you know, again, he was not a very religious person. My mother, though Jewish, you know, she never disavowed her Judaism, but…
Thomas Adler: But she wasn't devout, either. You know, so…
Thomas Adler: you know, I don't think it was a problem for her living in
Thomas Adler: Frenchburg, Kentucky, where there were few, if any, Jews, but
Thomas Adler: She told me stories about when she was in… when she first got to Iowa.
Thomas Adler: where she said there were no Jews, and, you know, the idea there was of Jews? They must have horns and tails, you know? I mean, the notion of Jews there was basically unknown or prejudiced, you know, but
Thomas Adler: Without any real knowledge. But at any rate, my parents met in 43.
Thomas Adler: and married in… on July 4th in 1943.
Thomas Adler: And, of course, Independence Day, my dad liked to make jokes about losing his independence, then.
Thomas Adler: For years after.
Thomas Adler: And, I will mention, I can, on my website and in other places, I've,
Thomas Adler: I'm very proud of the fact that, the RKO Motion Picture Company.
Thomas Adler: made a series of short films back in the 40s and early 50s. Of course, when you went to the movies, usually you'd see a feature film, but also a cartoon, a newsreel, and a short, which was about a 20-minute film on some subject. RKO, which was a major studio.
Thomas Adler: made a series of shorts in the 1940s called, new Americans.
Thomas Adler: And they were, frankly, propaganda aimed at Americans, to…
Thomas Adler: To, convey the idea that, you know, all these, immigrants
Thomas Adler: that have come out of Europe.
Thomas Adler: Are not a bad thing, because then, as now, there's always been prejudice against large waves of immigration.
Thomas Adler: And… So… they made a New American's film.
Thomas Adler: That was about 20 minutes long, that featured
Thomas Adler: Immigrants that they thought, you know, contributed a good deal to
Thomas Adler: the United States. People like Albert Einstein, and the novelist Thomas Mann, And…
Thomas Adler: several others, there are some of the actors in that who might really be actors, as well as the real people shown in newsreel footage. And they included my father in this RKO short.
Thomas Adler: So, I… I eventually found that… that footage. Actually, RKO gave my parents a 16mm… hello?
Thomas Adler: I've just lost you somehow.
Julie Stout: Can you hear me?
Thomas Adler: I've lost the… the visual.
Thomas Adler: Let me see what's happening here.
Thomas Adler: Okay.
Julie Stout: Hmm.
Thomas Adler: Anyway, RKO made this, short film, New Americans, that included my father. It was about a 2-minute segment,
Thomas Adler: You know, where they…
Thomas Adler: they talk about, now let's go down to Frenchburg, Kentucky, this rural place. There's a shot of the sign. Even though Frenchburg was the county seat, at that time, in 1943, the population of the county seat was 300 people.
Thomas Adler: And they focused on my father because they thought it was remarkable that this guy who had been… this physician who had been practicing at… at an eminent hospital in Vienna was now
Thomas Adler: Driving up creek beds, and sometimes on horseback, and so on, in… in, kentucky… in rural Kentucky.
Thomas Adler: you know, was now serving the people there. So there's a film, and I think I have a link to that. I'm pretty sure I do on my website. Anyway, so my father and mother met in 43, married. There's this film, that focuses on my father, though there's a very brief shot of my mother
Thomas Adler: weighing an infant, you know, in an infant scale there. So, that was, you know, my parents.
Thomas Adler: my… my mother's… parents did not survive long. Her mother was
Thomas Adler: was, disappeared in 1942, and presumably killed by the Nazis. My mother tried to find out what became of her, and the trail vanished. She was probably taken to Theresienstadt and then to, Auschwitz, or somewhere.
Thomas Adler: Her husband, my mother's father,
Thomas Adler: died before that, you know, he was ill and passed away. On my father's side, again, both his parents came over,
Thomas Adler: And, his father.
Thomas Adler: lasted several years, and then he passed away, too. His mother lived a number of years longer, and was with him in Kentucky, and then after the war.
Thomas Adler: my married parents moved to Chicago, and and my grandmother, the only grandmother I ever knew, my father's mother lived there with us. Though she made periodic trips after the war back to Austria, she would come back and go back and forth.
Thomas Adler: I have two brothers. My older brother, Peter, was born
Thomas Adler: when my parents were still living in Kentucky, though they went to, Cincinnati.
Thomas Adler: For his birth, because they were the only physicians. My father wasn't going to deliver
Thomas Adler: his son, so he was actually born in Cincinnati.
Thomas Adler: It's my older brother, Peter.
Thomas Adler: And, and then… The war had ended, and my parents moved to Chicago.
Thomas Adler: I don't know all the reasons for that, but they were free to go, and
Thomas Adler: So they went to Chicago to, practice medicine there.
Thomas Adler: I was born in Chicago in 1947, and in 1952, my younger brother, Bob Adler, was born there. So I have the two brothers. Cultural or linguistic traditions at home. Well.
Thomas Adler: We spoke English, my parents used German as a kind of secret language from us. They didn't…
Thomas Adler: try to teach us German, but we heard a lot of German, you know, Austrian-German, so we could understand a good deal of it, not everything, you know, but they used it as a code that we couldn't always decipher.
Thomas Adler: That was the only…
Julie Stout: Is there… is there a reason why you think they didn't pass on the language to you, but beyond the…
Thomas Adler: Well…
Julie Stout: Corporate language.
Thomas Adler: I think they were, you know, they were busy being…
Thomas Adler: Americans themselves, you know? They had already… again, by the time
Thomas Adler: even by the time I was born in 47, and certainly by the time Bob came along in 52, you know, they had been in the U.S. for a number of years, for half a decade or more, and
Thomas Adler: You know, they were…
Thomas Adler: you know, they had learned English very well themselves. They had to, you know, communicate with Americans, and
Thomas Adler: So, I don't think they felt a pressing need to speak German anymore, except to each other.
Thomas Adler: And… and it was simply, you know, I don't think there was any strong reason for them to… to speak German to us. The, I don't… I don't think it was a very deeply reasoned decision on their part.
Thomas Adler: And as I say, once in a while, you know, if they wanted to say something and they didn't really want us to pick up on it, then they would switch to German. Viennese German is a little different from High German that you might hear in Germany or in other parts… even in other parts of Austria. There are
Thomas Adler: I've become aware that there are pronunciations that are different in Vienna than even in other parts of Austria, but… so they didn't pass that along to us.
Thomas Adler: early influences, you ask about, well, my parents were interested
Thomas Adler: you know, my brothers and I were, you know, growing up in the early 50s, and we were influenced by everything in American culture then. You know, we… we grew up hearing,
Thomas Adler: you know, American music of all kinds. We went to elementary schools and then high school in South Chicago, where we lived. We lived in a neighborhood called South Shore.
Thomas Adler: Which, at the time, was, an interesting mixture. It was… it was a very white neighborhood. At the time, my parents lived there.
Thomas Adler: that slowly integrated, and then very rapidly integrated. A lot of people… a lot of white people moved out in the late 50s, I would say. But at the time, you know, when I remember it as a child.
Thomas Adler: It was a neighborhood with both a strong Jewish presence and a strong Catholic presence. And, I mean, there was a big Catholic church nearby, and a lot of kids that we would sometimes play with.
Thomas Adler: you know, Irish kids around that we would play with, you know, throw rocks at, and they threw rocks at us, and… I mean, in play, we were friends with them, you know, and
Thomas Adler: And there were, you know, when I went to elementary school, there were a lot of kids that were, that I knew were going to Hebrew school and having bar mitzvahs and things. So, you know, I knew about that, that, those cultural
Thomas Adler: influences and elements around.
Julie Stout: And I know there's a big, like, German and Austrian population in Chicago. Did you feel that at all? Or…
Thomas Adler: Not really, because much of that was on… much of that was on the north or near-north side of Chicago, and we were in South Shore, which is,
Thomas Adler: Where I grew up, it was the, our address was near a place called, I mean, 73rd Street… 73rd and Jeffrey was more or less our address.
Thomas Adler: And if you were to go there today, you would see almost entirely Afro-American faces. It's black now, because in the late 50s and early 60s, there was a lot of white flight from that area as the area integrated.
Thomas Adler: And, and so…
Thomas Adler: you know, I was aware of all that. It didn't much matter to me one way or the other, but
Thomas Adler: But that was what was going on. Musically.
Thomas Adler: you know, my brothers and I listened to rock and roll like everyone else did, you know? We listened to Elvis, and what was on the radio, and Top 40 stuff.
Thomas Adler: Sometime early on, I started to listen to,
Thomas Adler: what I later learned was country music. You know, I would hear… I still have a…
Thomas Adler: pretty strong memory of… of hearing, Hank Williams early on, and being really impressed with the sound of Hank Williams.
Thomas Adler: And that would have been around 53 or 4, even… so I was pretty young, but I heard that sound, and I liked that. And then, you know, 54, 5, 6, you know, there was what was going on, Elvis and everything else.
Thomas Adler: You know, and Bill Haley in the comments, rock around the clock. All of that rock and roll, early, mid-50s rock and roll music.
Thomas Adler: the other important, most important early influence on me, musically, personally, was, I had a very close friend
Thomas Adler: A kid named Peter Hayward, and I used to go over to his house. He lived a few blocks away in South Shore.
Thomas Adler: And he… he… You know, I was interested in…
Thomas Adler: what we called, kind of, generally, folk music then, and so was he, and we both had some record collections and things, but I was at his house one time, and he said, hey, listen to this, and he put the needle down on a record by Lester Flatt and Earl Scruggs and the Foggy Mountain Boys.
Thomas Adler: It's the first time I ever heard that.
Thomas Adler: And it… it was like a…
Thomas Adler: conversion experience in my life. It really was.
Thomas Adler: I've told people… the, you know, that… I still have the record, or a copy of the same record that Peter played for me that day in his basement, and
Thomas Adler: there's a… well, there's… I know all the tunes on it, you know, but there was one on it called Shuckin' the Corn, you know, and I tell my bluegrass pals, you know, when I tell this story, I said, yeah, I heard that that day, and it shucked my corn for good. You know, it just… it totally made me want to play the banjo.
Thomas Adler: And by that time.
Thomas Adler: my older brother, Peter, he was caught up in the sort of mid-50s… mid to latter 50s folk music stuff, that was going on, the Kingston Trio, and later Peter, Paul, and Mary, and all of that. And he… he started playing guitar.
Thomas Adler: A little bit, and he had a friend who had a 4-string banjo, and he said, Tom, guitar and banjo go real well together, so you ought to buy my friend's banjo.
Thomas Adler: So I did.
Thomas Adler: it was a 4-string banjo, I didn't realize you couldn't do what Earl Scruggs was doing on a 4-string banjo.
Thomas Adler: But I learned to play chords on it like a guitar, you know, I tuned it like the top four strings of a guitar, so I was interested in that, but I soon learned that that was entirely the wrong kind of instrument to do what I had in my head.
Julie Stout: Are you, are you self-taught? Like, did you teach yourself this music, or who taught you?
Thomas Adler: Caught myself.
Julie Stout: Oh!
Thomas Adler: I mean, it was… there was nobody around that could play this. You know, I could do it, you know, what I did by ear.
Thomas Adler: And there was no one, particularly when it came to bluegrass or that Scruggs-style banjo playing, there was nobody at all in the south side of Chicago that did that.
Thomas Adler: Later, I actually… a little bit later, I went… you know, there was an institution in Chicago called the Old Town School of Folk Music.
Thomas Adler: And before I could even drive, I took
Thomas Adler: you know, the Illinois Central commuter train to downtown, and then a bus, and then a transfer to another bus, and…
Thomas Adler: And got myself to the Old Town School and said, well, I want to learn how to play this five-string banjo. And they said, oh, we can teach you that. And I said, I want to play like Earl Scruggs. And they said, oh, no, we don't do that.
Thomas Adler: we can… we play this old-time claw hammer-style banjo, you know, and I said, that's not what I'm after. And they said, well, we can't help. So…
Thomas Adler: They didn't know anything about it at that time, so…
Thomas Adler: So they were no help. You know, eventually I found some people that could show me a little bit, and I started hanging out at an important music store on the south side called The Fret Shop.
Thomas Adler: And… practically one note at a time, people would show me one little thing, you know, and I'd…
Thomas Adler: learned that, and I'd learn another thing.
Thomas Adler: So…
Thomas Adler: at any rate, the bluegrass music came slowly but powerfully into my life. Starting… I guess I… to this day, I date it around the time
Thomas Adler: when I was around 11 years old, so that would have been 1958 or so, when I really got swept up into bluegrass banjo and the sound of
Thomas Adler: Flatten Scruggs, and then Bill Monroe, and other bluegrass
Thomas Adler: artists, you know, and I'm still following it to this day.
Thomas Adler: Still involved with it in many, many ways.
Thomas Adler: So… That's, that's, the early influences.
Thomas Adler: My early education, I think, was your next topic on your list of questions.
Thomas Adler: Well, I… my earliest education was at
Thomas Adler: the elementary school that was literally across the street from our house at 73rd and Jeffrey, Bryn Mawr Public School.
Thomas Adler: Which no longer exists. The building is there, but it, it, I don't know quite when it happened, but it stopped being a public school, and turned into some kind of
Thomas Adler: Private institution.
Thomas Adler: you know, they… I don't know quite what it is, but there is no Bryn Mawr Public School anymore. So,
Thomas Adler: I wish there were such a place.
Thomas Adler: Yeah, once again, I keep, Clicking other things and losing…
Thomas Adler: the screen that I'm trying to see you on. Let me get it back here.
Thomas Adler: the Zoom… oh, there it is, the Zoom screen. Okay, so I went to, Bryn Mawr Public School.
Thomas Adler: through 8th grade, which is as much as we had, I had…
Thomas Adler: a serious medical problem when I was going into 8th grade. I had a problem that turned out to be a herniated disc in my back.
Thomas Adler: which…
Thomas Adler: you know, I was about 12 years old or something like that, and it went undiagnosed for a long time, even though my parents were both physicians, they didn't know quite what was wrong. And I never had pain in my back, just in my knee, that was referred from
Thomas Adler: You know, probably a disc pressing on a nerve in my back.
Thomas Adler: And they took me to various physicians who misdiagnosed it for a few months, and then finally, a neurosurgeon,
Thomas Adler: figured out what was going on, and ultimately, I had some surgery.
Thomas Adler: that took care of it. I was in the hospital a long time, and I still have a big, long scar on my back from the surgery then. Now they can do it with a teeny little incision, but it was… back then, it was a major thing. I was in the hospital for weeks, and
Thomas Adler: But after that was done,
Thomas Adler: then… and I was always a pretty good student, and I was about done with 8th grade, and my parents… my older brother, Peter, had gone on to, the local high school, South Shore High.
Thomas Adler: And I went there, I think, for…
Thomas Adler: one year, or maybe even just half a year, I don't know what it was, but…
Thomas Adler: But my folks thought that I had some potential for more, and they, reached into their wallets and sprung for,
Thomas Adler: for me to go to an expensive alternative, which was the University of Chicago Laboratory High School.
Thomas Adler: Now, lab school, as we called it, actually had a program that ran from kindergarten all the way through high school.
Thomas Adler: and of course, the University of Chicago University,
Thomas Adler: But, you know, I didn't get in there until I was a sophomore, in high school, so I joined… there was a small group, you know, the whole high school was about 125 or 130
Thomas Adler: people, very small. But it was a wonderful school for high school.
Thomas Adler: And I made… I had some good friends there, some of whom I played music with. Again, there were a few folks there that… that were, like me, into folk music and… and at least, marginally into the bluegrass music that I was consumed with by that time.
Thomas Adler: So…
Thomas Adler: the institution then was, was, lab school for me for the rest of high school. And then, beyond that, I,
Thomas Adler: I applied to, well, I forget all the schools I applied to, but I ended up going off for a couple years to Carleton College in Minnesota.
Thomas Adler: I didn't apply myself very well at Carleton College, and so… my father.
Julie Stout: What did you… what did you study at Carleton?
Thomas Adler: Well, the first year, it was, I had vague ideas of being pre-med, so I studied biology and maybe some chemistry, but I, as I say, I didn't really apply myself.
Thomas Adler: And didn't do very well in terms of my grades. I just… I slacked off too much.
Thomas Adler: But,
Thomas Adler: And so, after a couple years there, I transferred. My father was very annoyed at my poor performance, you know, in terms of grades, and the costs were high.
Thomas Adler: And so, he said he's not going to put up with that anymore, and so I ended up transferring then to the University of Illinois in Champaign.
Thomas Adler: Champaign, Illinois. And that's where I finished up. Now, not everything transferred, so even though I had done 2 years at Carleton, it took me 3 more years to graduate from Illinois. However, there was a really bright side, as far as I was concerned.
Thomas Adler: Which was, not only did I… I graduated from Illinois with, let's see, a degree in English,
Thomas Adler: But one of my professors there was a… proved to be a truly important mentor for me.
Thomas Adler: And he was a folklorist and labor, industrial labor scholar named Archie Green.
Thomas Adler: Archie Green.
Thomas Adler: to this day, is well thought of, and he passed away a few years ago, but he was a renowned figure in the world of folklore, and
Thomas Adler: You know, I was… I was involved in all of that. I was…
Thomas Adler: there was a campus folk song club at Illinois, I participated in all that, and…
Thomas Adler: you know, met musicians around there. I became a president of the Campus Folk Song Club, I took…
Thomas Adler: You know, I wrote papers for, both for Archie's classes and… and there were some little publications we had, and he had me writing papers for that.
Thomas Adler: And… And I didn't really realize before I knew Archie that there was an academic field called folklore.
Thomas Adler: And he made me aware of that. And so, by the time I graduated from the University of Illinois.
Thomas Adler: Archie said, you know, you really ought to go on and get a master's in folklore, at the very least, and
Thomas Adler: Archie thought what I should do is go get a master's. There was a master's program in Cooperstown, New York.
Thomas Adler: The Cooperstown Graduate Program. They actually had two different master's programs, one in
Thomas Adler: History museums, you know, for people who wanted to pursue museum studies, and one in folklore.
Thomas Adler: And so, with Archie's strong support, I applied to and got into the folklore program at Cooperstown. It was a one-year program.
Thomas Adler: And Archie thought that after doing that, that I would then go on, perhaps to the PhD program at the University of Pennsylvania.
Thomas Adler: I think I disappointed him, because I did do the master's at Cooperstown, but then I ended up going to
Thomas Adler: Indiana University for the doctorate.
Thomas Adler: And, of course, that's where I met Dawson.
Thomas Adler: And… Dorrison, I think, in his… in fact, in the Folklore Forum issue, where he talks about
Thomas Adler: the Gary gang, he even mentions that I have, you know, came in with an MA from Cooperstown.
Thomas Adler: So, Dawson knew, you know, before I ever met Dawson, he knew that I was an MA folklore student, he knew that I had a strong interest in music.
Thomas Adler: And he knew about the bluegrass music, or southern hillbilly, Appalachian music interests, so all of that was stuff that Dawson knew about me before I ever met him.
Thomas Adler: You know, when I got there. Because, I guess, you know, I don't know what was said in the communications, but the director at Cooperstown, the folklore director, there was a man named,
Thomas Adler: Well, the actual program director was Lewis Jones, but then there was Bruce Buckley, who did the folklore program, and I'm sure they both wrote supportive letters to Dawson that helped me get into Indiana.
Thomas Adler: And so all of this was known to Dawson, and Buckley and Jones were both mentors. I will mention, as well, that
Thomas Adler: while I was at Cooperstown, I met one of the museum students there, a…
Thomas Adler: woman from Milwaukee, or near Milwaukee, Wisconsin, named Elizabeth Mosby, or Betsy Mosby.
Thomas Adler: And the two of us married.
Thomas Adler: In fact, we married at Cooperstown, there's a…
Thomas Adler: place there that was, at least then, called the Farmer's Museum. They had a museum in Cooperstown with an 1840s
Thomas Adler: church as part of the museum, and that's where we married, and so we have a lot of photos there, including photos that our classmates took, and
Thomas Adler: Lou Jones and his wife took photos and sent them all to us. Part of the program there was helping us develop photographic skills, so…
Thomas Adler: you know, so all our classmates took photos and shared them with us, so we had a lot of photos, and all of those are in my iMatch.
Julie Stout: I love that, yeah. What year did you get married?
Thomas Adler: 197.
Julie Stout: Okay.
Thomas Adler: And so, I think that's…
Thomas Adler: That's the biggest part of the biographic.
Julie Stout: Yeah!
Thomas Adler: You know, that I can tell you about.
Julie Stout: I had, a follow-up question, if that's okay for you.
Thomas Adler: Sure.
Julie Stout: You started off doing maybe pre-med, which I'm sure your parents were pretty happy about?
Thomas Adler: Yeah.
Julie Stout: You say? What drew you to switch that up and go to English instead? Was it your love of music? Was it your love of, like.
Julie Stout: arts, or…
Thomas Adler: Well, I was an English major.
Thomas Adler: you know, was, once I… once I…
Thomas Adler: kind of failed at the pre-med thing, you know, by not applying myself very much in doing,
Thomas Adler: You know, the… the, concentrated work in
Thomas Adler: chemistry and biology, at Carleton. I really did not apply myself as I should, and it's… it can be a difficult field.
Thomas Adler: But, at… at Illinois.
Thomas Adler: You know what? I don't think I had to declare a major right away, but
Thomas Adler: But English was a sort of a catch-all.
Thomas Adler: field, you know, you could…
Thomas Adler: do almost anything with an English major. And, you know, I always read a lot anyway, so,
Thomas Adler: it was an easy thing to fall into as a major, you know, take literature classes, and some of Archie's classes, you know, were listed or cross-listed under literature fields, you know, it's,
Thomas Adler: So, I think it was just sort of a default, you know, that I got into. And it worked pretty well.
Thomas Adler: And as I say, Archie's the one that pointed me at folklore as an academic discipline.
Thomas Adler: And that's what led me first to Cooperstown, and then I got myself to Indiana.
Thomas Adler: of…
Thomas Adler: You know, and it's not that I didn't like the idea of medicine or pre-med, you know, and I'm sure to some degree I had disappointed my parents by not pursuing that.
Thomas Adler: But, you know, they were pretty pleased, you know, I think, anyway, that I'd gone on to graduate school in any form, you know, and my older brother, Peter, also did a graduate degree. He ended up, you know, he did a PhD in sociology.
Thomas Adler: And, you know, has… so…
Thomas Adler: You know, we've done okay, you know, and my, my parents.
Thomas Adler: unfortunately passed away far too young. My,
Thomas Adler: They, they died in the early 70s, so they, you know, they were both…
Thomas Adler: alive when… when I'm married.
Thomas Adler: So they were at… when Betsy and I married in 1971, they were there For that, but,
Thomas Adler: But, you know, didn't live much longer than that, so they didn't… you know, they,
Thomas Adler: you know, they didn't… they didn't know that I eventually got the PhD. I forget if my older brother had gotten his doctorate by then or not, but and we've both published books since then, and we've… we've been…
Thomas Adler: reasonably successful at what we've attempted since then. So, we think they would have…
Thomas Adler: Been supportive all the way along.
Thomas Adler: Since then, you know, you never know what they would have thought, but…
Julie Stout: I'm sure they would feel pride, at the very least.
Thomas Adler: One hopes, you know?
Julie Stout: One hopes. What did you specifically study in your master's program?
Thomas Adler: Well, that was interesting. I was…
Thomas Adler: I… I was interested in a number of things. Of course, in the master's program at Cooperstown, we were directed to do a number of things. Fieldwork was a very strong concentration. We were… we were really directed to do,
Thomas Adler: To get out and work
Thomas Adler: directly with informants, and they had a series of… of classes that they called practicums, where we were… we were really taught how to do photography. I mean.
Thomas Adler: you know, not just, here's a camera, go take some pictures, but this is what an f-stop is. Here's, you know, what depth of field means, here's how to do it, as well as
Thomas Adler: You know, here's how to comport yourself when you're working with people out, you know, and you want to take
Thomas Adler: photos of them, and you want to use a tape recorder, and we even… even though it was in the early 70s, they had some early video machines, video machines that we could use. I didn't use those very much.
Thomas Adler: And, knowing of my connection with music and the,
Thomas Adler: you know, the fact that I liked Southern music and played the banjo and all that, Bruce Buckley, the director.
Thomas Adler: said, oh, you need to go see this fellow, Dorrance Weir. Dorrance Weir was a farmer and carpenter who had a little farm out in the country a few miles away, who was quite a character.
Thomas Adler: In his own right, and… And he… he…
Thomas Adler: played guitar and sang and… and loved Southern music himself, you know, knew a lot of old, old country music, and so Dorrance and I hit it off right away. He loved to have me come out and play banjo while he played the guitar, and
Thomas Adler: And Betsy and I, you know, we weren't married then when I first met Dorrance, but we would both go out and hang out with Dorrance and his wife, Edie.
Thomas Adler: he was building a little barn, and we would help him with his barn. We would hang out and, you know, take some pictures, and
Thomas Adler: And we would do things together. One of the first projects I remember that Buckley sent us out to do was Dorrance was going to be butchering hogs in the… in the… once the weather got cold in the fall, and it was like, go out there and document that, you know, so…
Thomas Adler: So… the direction at Cooperstown was very practical in those ways. Get out and work with
Thomas Adler: People… we didn't, you know, say informants exactly, but it's…
Thomas Adler: go out and meet them, and learn what you can, get along. Develop… again, we didn't say rapport exactly, but that's what it amounted to, was get to know these people, see how you get along with them, and with Dorrance and Edie Weir, that was…
Thomas Adler: No problem. We spent a lot of time, we had many meals together, you know, either
Thomas Adler: you know, at their table, you know, Edie would fix dinners for us, or just sitting around a fire, working on their barn.
Thomas Adler: Whatever, and so we spent a lot of time with them. There were other folks as well,
Thomas Adler: And we knew, in the time we were there, there were other
Thomas Adler: other folklore students, that we worked with for a while. There was a…
Thomas Adler: I was actually there. It was a one-year program. The… the idea was you would take classes for one year and then write a thesis.
Thomas Adler: And that was the end of the MA program.
Thomas Adler: I did a thesis on, archiving, And…
Thomas Adler: where I kind of developed a plan which seems hopelessly archaic now, because this was all sort of pre-computers. I might mention that I started to work with computers when I was in high school.
Thomas Adler: There were no personal computers, but
Thomas Adler: one of my best pals in high school at lab school, his older brother worked in the University of Chicago computing labs on some very large mainframes, so we had access to some things, and I did some projects, you know, all the data was key-punched back then, and
Thomas Adler: We, you know, I was never scared of computers, and did some little projects, helped a sociologist,
Thomas Adler: manipulate data. It was mostly just simple counts of data, you know, on a longitudinal study of… of her,
Thomas Adler: you know, her informants, or her folks, back when I was in high school, and… at,
Thomas Adler: at Cooperstown then, so I did a… a… You know, now very forgettable.
Thomas Adler: Master's thesis on the archive of… and…
Thomas Adler: when I was done, you know, with my year of classes, they asked me to stay on for a second year and serve as the archivist of the New York State Historical Association.
Thomas Adler: So I spent a second year there. And meanwhile, Betsy, she was very interested in textiles, so she took a job in Harrisburg, Pennsylvania, and I would drive down there
Thomas Adler: Periodically to visit with her.
Thomas Adler: But I was still in Cooperstown, and that second year, I roomed with a, an absolutely wonderful,
Thomas Adler: folklore student who had also been around and had stayed longer, Gerald Parsons, who eventually worked at the Library of Congress
Thomas Adler: And died far too young, unfortunately, but he worked in the American Folklife Center at the Library of Congress.
Thomas Adler: and was, I mean, he was a friend and a roommate, and in so many ways, a mentor as well, even though he was just a few years older than I was. And,
Thomas Adler: So, I spent a happy second year there.
Thomas Adler: at Cooperstown, and as I say, then Betsy and I married.
Thomas Adler: And, literally the day after our wedding, we packed up a U-Haul truck and, you know, and moved to Bloomington.
Thomas Adler: So… Because I had been accepted by then to the program at IU, the PhD program.
Julie Stout: What drew you to get more schooling? What was your, like, goal for a career at that point?
Thomas Adler: Well, I'm not sure I had it, you know, had really articulated the goal very well, but I was, I knew that,
Thomas Adler: Again, it was this consuming interest still in, in folklore, and specifically folk music, folk song, and, you know, underneath it all, bluegrass music, and
Thomas Adler: archie Green, again, because I was… have joined the American Folklore Society,
Thomas Adler: Archie Green, back in as early as 1968,
Thomas Adler: had introduced me to Neil Rosenberg. I don't know if that's a name you know or not.
Thomas Adler: Neil Rosenberg, to this day, is a close friend and another person I would consider a mentor of mine. Neil had been a graduate student
Thomas Adler: at IU as well. And, you know, he was several years… there were several years before me, And…
Thomas Adler: I'm sure his presence there, influenced my decision to go to IU rather than Penn, where Archie kind of wanted me to go.
Thomas Adler: Because Neil… I think of Neil now as
Thomas Adler: The father of bluegrass music scholarship.
Thomas Adler: He's… he has written a number of books,
Thomas Adler: and many, many articles through the years. In 1985, he published a book called Bluegrass, A History.
Thomas Adler: Which was… I mean, it's the first… well, it wasn't the first, there was actually a man in Japan that wrote the very first
Thomas Adler: book about bluegrass, but the first book in English was written by Neil Rosenberg, And Archie introduced us,
Thomas Adler: And we actually sat at a table together at the American Folklore Society meeting in New Orleans in 1968, and I was always impressed by Neil Rosenberg.
Thomas Adler: A wonderful social person, like myself, a banjo player, though he also plays guitar and mandolin, and he's just a thoroughly nice man.
Thomas Adler: And, he, he's, written…
Thomas Adler: many things, you know, other books, written and edited books. Always been interested in, kind of, the intersection of popular music and folk music, if I can put it that way.
Thomas Adler: And… You know, after he… got his PhD,
Thomas Adler: he went to, St. John's University in Newfoundland, Canada.
Thomas Adler: and spent his career there. He… he, became… he finished up there, I think, in 2005.
Thomas Adler: and is an emeritus professor of folklore at St. John's. He oversaw many, many graduate students' careers there, and is highly thought of there. There's a lot of websites at St. John's University.
Thomas Adler: you know, celebrating Neil and all his work there. So I think it was Neil's presence as much as anything.
Thomas Adler: that, that drew me to Indiana, and even though we were not really there at the same time, he was gone by the time I got there, but it was…
Thomas Adler: It was his work that got me
Thomas Adler: to go there in the first place. One more very important point, though, about Neil.
Thomas Adler: Even though he was… Deeply into bluegrass music, and…
Thomas Adler: wanted… you know, he probably should have written his dissertation at Indiana about bluegrass music.
Thomas Adler: Dawson didn't let him.
Thomas Adler: Dawson was always suspicious.
Thomas Adler: of… people who… How can I put it? People who
Thomas Adler: Who were immersed in the kind of same thing that they studied.
Thomas Adler: Okay, so… Dawson really discouraged Neil.
Thomas Adler: from doing a dissertation that related to bluegrass music, because Neil had been so deeply involved with it,
Thomas Adler: And Dawson knew that. So Neil's dissertation ended up being about parrot jokes.
Thomas Adler: And I'm sure it was a fine dissertation. Got him done, he got his PhD.
Thomas Adler: And then later wrote some wonderful books and articles.
Thomas Adler: And, as I say, he's, in my opinion, the father of bluegrass music scholarship.
Thomas Adler: But that didn't really happen while he was at Indiana, because Dawson kind of put his foot down. When I…
Thomas Adler: Wanted to do my own dissertation which was entitled.
Thomas Adler: The acquisition of a traditional competence, folk musical and folk cultural learning among bluegrass banjo players.
Thomas Adler: Dawson literally said to me.
Thomas Adler: I don't think Dawson ever quite understood what I was driving at, but he knew it was bluegrass. And Dawson literally said, well, I didn't let Neil do this, and maybe that was a mistake.
Thomas Adler: So, Dawson let me do what I wanted to do, by the way of a dissertation topic.
Thomas Adler: And my relationship with Dawson was always a bit fraught.
Thomas Adler: in that way. Dorson was not on my committee, I don't believe, my dissertation committee.
Thomas Adler: I had Henry Glassie and Edson Richmond and, you know, ballad folks at Warren Roberts, at Indiana.
Thomas Adler: Dawson, you know, remained a little bit aloof, because he always had that suspicion, I felt, Of people who…
Thomas Adler: Who kind of practiced or were deeply involved in
Thomas Adler: Performing or being too deeply involved with something that they would also study.
Thomas Adler: So…
Thomas Adler: So that… that… there was a little… I wouldn't even call it friction there, but there was a distance between Dorsen
Thomas Adler: and me.
Thomas Adler: In that regard. And as I say, that thing that I just told you about, I think that was a very telling remark when he said to me, I didn't let Neil do this.
Thomas Adler: You know, and perhaps I should have, is what he said. So, he knew he made a mistake, because Neil was… was and is absolutely brilliant, you know, and…
Thomas Adler: And… A first-class scholar in every respect, and
Thomas Adler: And Dawson, you know, came to realize that he had perhaps made a mistake in
Thomas Adler: you know, directing Neil to go off and do a dissertation on parrot jokes. I'm sure it was… I've never read it, I'm sure it was a fine dissertation, but…
Thomas Adler: it was a waste of Neil's time in many ways, you know.
Julie Stout: And he went on to do more scholarship on bluegrass anyways, and so… Much more. Much more. Much more, much more, and influence you and your trajectory and everything, I'm sure, as well, so…
Thomas Adler: Yes, and… and lots of other people as well.
Julie Stout: Lots of other people. Yeah.
Thomas Adler: So… so I can't, overemphasize the importance of Neil Rosenberg. I'll say one last thing about Neil.
Thomas Adler: in 2007, Neil… well, two more things.
Thomas Adler: Neil had, in… in 19…
Thomas Adler: let me think if I get the year right. In 1963, Bill Monroe, who is often called the father of bluegrass music.
Thomas Adler: owned a music park in Bean Blossom, Indiana, which you're probably familiar with. It's changed a lot since Bill owned it. It's gone through several owners since then.
Thomas Adler: Neil first took me there in 1968.
Thomas Adler: And… when Bill was still alive and owned it.
Thomas Adler: And… but in 1963, for one year, Neil managed that park.
Thomas Adler: Neil was called on, that year.
Thomas Adler: Bill Monroe's career was being managed in a way, by Ralph Rensler. Do you know that name? Ralph Rensler.
Julie Stout: The Rensler Archives, right?
Thomas Adler: Yeah, of course, Ralph Rensler, and rensler was deeply involved with Monroe at the time, and Rensler, I think, had recommended Neil
Thomas Adler: to manage the Brown County Jamboree, which was the music park that Bill owned at Bean Blossom.
Thomas Adler: Because… You know, apart from
Thomas Adler: Apart from that, Bill's older brother, Birch Monroe, kind of did the management, but very haphazardly, Birch was
Thomas Adler: A charming old man, but didn't do a good job. And,
Thomas Adler: So, Neil, for one year, managed the Brown County Jamboree in 63.
Thomas Adler: And… And Neil had other connections with… with Bill Monroe.
Thomas Adler: in… And some of these have been written about in various books that Neil has put out since then.
Thomas Adler: In 2000 and… let's see, in 1974, Neil published
Thomas Adler: the first ever discography of Bill Monroe's music.
Thomas Adler: which was, I mean, discographies are complicated, because they're…
Thomas Adler: You know, you're literally trying to list
Thomas Adler: You know, every record, and it's…
Thomas Adler: the publisher, the master number, the session number, all the releases, and it was a very preliminary one, published by the Country Music Foundation in 1974. It's long out of print.
Thomas Adler: But with a lot of additional work.
Thomas Adler: Neil and Charles K. Wolfe, who was, another,
Thomas Adler: wonderful scholar that I knew somewhat, worked with a little bit, in 2007, published… the music of Bill Monroe.
Thomas Adler: Which is the revised discography. This is after Bill Monroe's death in 1996. This is the final
Thomas Adler: discography, if you will, of the music of Bill Monroe, along with a whole lot of commentary about every session, every song, every artist, everything.
Thomas Adler: And… For the last… month or two, I've been working with Neil. That was published in 2007,
Thomas Adler: And there have been a lot of,
Thomas Adler: additions and corrections that various folks have… have noticed since then. Well, the press, University Press of Illinois, is not about to reprint the book.
Thomas Adler: Because those things are very expensive to do.
Thomas Adler: But Neil asked if there was a way
Thomas Adler: to do the additions and corrections somehow. And I said, well, I can make websites, So…
Thomas Adler: I've been building a website
Thomas Adler: for Neil Rosenberg that features a whole lot of things about Neil, his VITA, his… all his publications, a lot of photos and videos and things about Neil, because those were never all in one place either. But a key part of it is
Thomas Adler: the additions and corrections to the music of Bill Monroe, to that book.
Thomas Adler: And we haven't yet made that… it's not hidden.
Thomas Adler: But we haven't yet told the, you know, the interested bluegrass world about it. Neil has been off, at the funeral of a close friend of his for the past couple of weeks.
Thomas Adler: But once he's back.
Thomas Adler: You know, pretty soon we may make that a public statement saying, okay, if you want all the additions and corrections to that, the printed version, here's where you go to find them.
Thomas Adler: So it's a website I've built for Neil. And so we've been in close contact ever since. He… he's reluctant to come to the U.S. now, given the political situation here. So he and his wife, Terry, are…
Thomas Adler: Staying pretty much in Canada, but
Thomas Adler: But Neil has visited, Neil and his wife Terry have visited many times. We've played a lot of music together. He's a… I regard him as a good friend, as well as a mentor, and an important person in my life, but
Thomas Adler: So, that… that website is something I've been working on very actively the last few weeks.
Thomas Adler: Anyway…
Julie Stout: The way that you talk about him, my follow-up was if you're still, like, in active contact, and you just answered that, so…
Thomas Adler: Oh, yes. Yes.
Julie Stout: Yeah. And…
Julie Stout: My follow-up was to ask how… what you were doing now, and so you mentioned the website. Is there anything else you've been working on?
Thomas Adler: Well, I work on websites and videos of all sorts.
Thomas Adler: I have, I didn't really tell you About, you know.
Julie Stout: Oh, yes, I'm so sorry, I forgot to ask about your career, and what happened after you graduated.
Thomas Adler: Would you mind.
Julie Stout: And starting with that first, and then.
Thomas Adler: Let me, let me go through that, at least.
Julie Stout: Yeah, thank you.
Thomas Adler: At least in a general way. So, yeah, let's see, after…
Thomas Adler: after I was done at IU and had the PhD, I…
Thomas Adler: I looked around, I mean, there were… there was a question of what… what positions are available.
Thomas Adler: And… They're a position came up at the University of Kentucky, here in Lexington.
Thomas Adler: And… And so, I applied for it. There were already 3 folklorists here at the time,
Thomas Adler: Gerald Alvey was one. Neil Grobman was another. They had both gotten doctorates at, Penn.
Thomas Adler: And a very good friend of mine who was a colleague at Bloomington, Jim Leary.
Thomas Adler: And Jim and I were close friends, and his… he had married Janet Gilmore, who was also a colleague at Bloomington.
Thomas Adler: And so Jim and Janet were already here.
Thomas Adler: And I applied for the position, and got…
Thomas Adler: that position. So, came to Lexington.
Thomas Adler: They… there was no folklore department. We were all, part of the English department here at the University of Kentucky.
Thomas Adler: it was a very strange English department. It had a number of
Thomas Adler: not always friendly concentrations, you might say. There was… Women's studies was in the English department. There was, of course.
Thomas Adler: English literature and American literature, and they didn't always get along. There was a film group in the English department, and then there were us folklorists in the English department. This was in the
Thomas Adler: in the,
Thomas Adler: end of the 70s, early 80s, and I finished my dissertation in 79, I think my… the PhD technically is 1980.
Thomas Adler: That I got. So, as of 1980, or the fall of 79, I was here in Lexington.
Thomas Adler: And…
Thomas Adler: That was a tough time for all of us, in a way, in the humanities, in the English department, regardless of which of those subgroups we represented in the English department, because at that point, humanities in general were going through a tough period.
Thomas Adler: We were, you know, students were either going into business or computer science. They were kind of abandoning humanities, out of a sense of,
Thomas Adler: Finding more lucrative fields to, to, to follow up on.
Thomas Adler: So…
Thomas Adler: what that meant for us was that, you know, we would see declining enrollments to our folklore classes. And and our folklore classes also did not
Thomas Adler: Lead to… they didn't contribute to,
Thomas Adler: what did they call it? The, you know, they didn't help
Thomas Adler: Students a lot in terms of,
Thomas Adler: Their other majors. You know, they were more or less electives.
Thomas Adler: And so that wasn't a great help to the undergraduate students. There was no graduate program here.
Thomas Adler: So we all saw some declining enrollments, and that meant that we ended up teaching, all of us, taught more, composition classes and things like that, which was no fun at all.
Thomas Adler: I mean, I could do it.
Thomas Adler: But it really wasn't what I felt like I had signed up to do.
Thomas Adler: And that got worse and worse over the… The next few years.
Thomas Adler: And… To cut to the chase,
Thomas Adler: Alvey, Gerald Alvey, was the most senior of our group, And he…
Thomas Adler: Went up for tenure and got it, but kind of by the skin of his teeth, is what we heard.
Thomas Adler: Groveman went up for tenure next, did not make it.
Thomas Adler: then Jim Leary went up for tenure and also didn't make it. And that was a shock to me and
Thomas Adler: to everyone who knew him, because he had published a good deal by then, and those of us who knew him could see that he was already within the field, and even nationally and internationally. He was a star, a rising star.
Thomas Adler: And it was… it was like, what's… what's going on? If…
Thomas Adler: If all of our colleagues in the English department don't have the wit to see who Jim Leary is.
Thomas Adler: And to give him tenure?
Thomas Adler: Something's wrong.
Thomas Adler: And I'd say largely as a consequence of that, I had some publications, but nothing sufficient, I thought.
Thomas Adler: to get over that hurdle, so I didn't even try. I did not pursue a 10-year decision. So after 7 years, or 7 and a half years, whatever it was.
Thomas Adler: I left the University of Kentucky.
Thomas Adler: So, that was the end of my academic involvement with UK.
Thomas Adler: So, I looked around to see…
Thomas Adler: what's next? What can I do? I had a neighbor
Thomas Adler: As I say, I had worked with computers all my life, practically, since high school, and by this time, there were personal computers and so on.
Thomas Adler: I had a neighbor who,
Thomas Adler: Was involved with a local chain of computer stores.
Thomas Adler: But he wasn't a salesman.
Thomas Adler: He had started what he thought of as a support division
Thomas Adler: to, this company, CBM Computers. CBM out of resonance with IBM, because they didn't sell Macs, it was really an IBM
Thomas Adler: support company, and they had about 90 stores at their peak all over the eastern United States. And my neighbor, Harold.
Thomas Adler: said,
Thomas Adler: you know, after he knew I was free, he said, well, Tom, you understand a lot about publishing, you understand computers.
Thomas Adler: It says, why don't you come to CBM and join my support group?
Thomas Adler: You don't have to sell computers, but I'm trying to create a support group to support the whole company.
Thomas Adler: with this new thing that was happening then called desktop publishing. Now, Apple had
Thomas Adler: pioneered desktop publishing in the Mac world.
Thomas Adler: And it… and people in the IBM world didn't even know about it. And they certainly didn't understand the terminology of publishing at all. They didn't… they didn't know the difference between a font and a typeface, and kerning, and leading, and all these publication terms.
Thomas Adler: And they certainly didn't know how to do any of that on a PC.
Thomas Adler: And the software for doing it was very… on an IBM PC, was very primitive.
Thomas Adler: But I agreed, I needed a job, and I thought I could do that, so I joined the CBM support
Thomas Adler: group.
Thomas Adler: Which meant that I, for the most part, stayed in Lexington for the next few years, and worked with Harold and other support personnel. They had support people in other specific areas, people that worked with
Thomas Adler: spreadsheets, people that worked with, accounting and… and so on. But I was… I was kind of the,
Thomas Adler: the desk… they're the publishing guy. We didn't even call it desktop publishing, but it was publishing.
Thomas Adler: And I would help educate not only the local sales folks here in Lexington.
Thomas Adler: But I ended up traveling to IBM centers all around the country to put on seminars, you know, where they'd bring in people who were interested in, well, how do you do this, you know? What do you do
Thomas Adler: you know, if you're trying to get away from typesetters or something like that, you know, and how does it work, and what kind of software is there? There were early pieces of software, like PageMaker, and
Thomas Adler: And so on. And so I would put on seminars, and eventually I had a partner who was a pretty slick talker, a fellow named Wood Simpson,
Thomas Adler: And, and, you know, he…
Thomas Adler: Wood and I would travel around and do these things, whether it was in Ohio somewhere, or Nashville, Tennessee, or whatever, we'd do these seminars, and
Thomas Adler: you know, we didn't really have to sell computers ourselves, which was good, because I didn't want to do that. But we were the publishing folks, and
Thomas Adler: It gave me the time to also keep learning about things that were going on in the computer world, like video production on computers, and things that were happening in the late 80s and early 90s.
Thomas Adler: And… Anyway, so I did that for a while.
Thomas Adler: And all the while, kept Being involved with bluegrass music, one way or another.
Thomas Adler: That led to… A contact from,
Thomas Adler: An organization that had formed in Owensboro, Kentucky, called the International Bluegrass Music Association.
Thomas Adler: the… the, they approached me, they were trying to start a museum.
Thomas Adler: that they… thought of as the international… well, first of all, the International Bluegrass Music Association
Thomas Adler: asked if I would join their board of directors, just because I knew about bluegrass.
Thomas Adler: And had enough of a background in various things that they thought I might be helpful. So I did that for a year or two, and then as they got
Thomas Adler: closer and closer to the idea of starting an actual bluegrass music museum in Owensboro.
Thomas Adler: They ended up ultimately hiring me to be the first executive director of the International Bluegrass Music Museum.
Thomas Adler: And that happened around 1994.
Thomas Adler: So I moved to Owensboro.
Thomas Adler: Betsy and I sold the house that we had been working on restoring here in Lexington, an old house that we loved.
Thomas Adler: And, we bought a house in Owensboro.
Thomas Adler: And… To make a long story short, it really didn't work out.
Julie Stout: I was about to say, were you excited going in? That seems kind of like a… maybe not dream job, but you get to combine your interests of education, maybe management a little bit there, and your research.
Thomas Adler: Yes, I was very excited going.
Julie Stout: Yeah.
Thomas Adler: But it, for a number of reasons, not all of which I understand to this day, it didn't work, okay? It didn't work out. I had a board of directors.
Thomas Adler: that I thought I could… excuse me, that I thought I could rely on for help.
Thomas Adler: The biggest need for a new museum, and maybe for existing museums always, is fundraising. Always. And…
Thomas Adler: They… really didn't help me.
Thomas Adler: With that, with that in particular.
Thomas Adler: You know, they were… The board was… was critical, But… but not very helpful.
Thomas Adler: And after about, almost 2 years,
Thomas Adler: you know, they, you know, ultimately, they fired me for reasons I still…
Thomas Adler: They never made clear to me.
Thomas Adler: You know, it's like, did I not raise enough money?
Thomas Adler: Is that it?
Thomas Adler: you know, was I… was there something else going on? I'm not sure what it was. And there was, you know, there were some meetings after that happened.
Thomas Adler: And they never quite made it clear to me.
Thomas Adler: And I had some friends on the board, and they couldn't really
Thomas Adler: explain what had happened either. But…
Thomas Adler: The long and the short of it is, I came back to Lexington.
Thomas Adler: And, you know, of course, very disheartened, you know, here I lost this job.
Thomas Adler: and didn't quite know what I was gonna do.
Thomas Adler: But… My old partner at CBM, the guy I had done those desktop publishing seminars with, Wood Simpson.
Thomas Adler: In the meantime, he had married
Thomas Adler: A very successful orthopedic surgeon, a woman named Dr. Mary Lloyd Ireland.
Thomas Adler: And Dr. Ireland had a thriving private practice, but she…
Thomas Adler: needed help in some ways, with her practice, and Wood said, why don't you come work for Dr. Ireland?
Thomas Adler: you can do, at the very least, you can do some things with collections, which I didn't want to do, but, you know, trying to get people to pay up their debts.
Thomas Adler: You know? And there's other things, too. And it turned out there were a lot of other things. She had…
Thomas Adler: You know, she would take Notes, she was a wonderful teacher.
Thomas Adler: And she would write up these extensive notes and have her secretaries type them up, but then they just would go into a three-ring binder, and I said.
Thomas Adler: you need databases, because I was, by that time, I was working with electronic databases and knew my way around some database software. I said.
Thomas Adler: This is stuff, you know, we could retrieve it with databases.
Thomas Adler: So I set up databases and did some other things for her, and became fairly indispensable to Dr. Ireland in her practice, her private practice. That lasted until the, I don't have an exact date, but maybe 2001 or 2, somewhere in there.
Thomas Adler: And then she had some disappointments with her private practice. She had a business manager who stole from her.
Thomas Adler: And, she… that didn't come out right away, but…
Thomas Adler: And it's very difficult, you know, to run a private medical practice.
Thomas Adler: And also to be a great doctor as well, you know, a wonderful surgeon.
Thomas Adler: So… And for years, the University of Kentucky had been imploring Dr. Ireland to
Thomas Adler: Close her private practice and come join them.
Thomas Adler: So finally, she decided to do that. So she closed down Kentucky Sports Medicine, which was her practice.
Thomas Adler: and joined… the University of Kentucky's Department of Orthopedic Surgery and Sports Medicine.
Thomas Adler: And when she did that, I was very happy that she
Thomas Adler: I still don't know what she had to say or do to do it, but she took me and a couple others along.
Thomas Adler: So I became an IT support person to that whole department. And I already mentioned to you that once I was in that environment, then I had to do IT support for all the doctors and the
Thomas Adler: the, not only the attending surgeons, but… but also the fellows who were there for a period of 4 or 5 years. All of them
Thomas Adler: generating papers and PowerPoint shows and teaching materials, and that's when I learned about iMatch, you know, but… but so that was that period of time, and I stayed there until
Thomas Adler: I retired in 2013.
Thomas Adler: So, again, and even though I was doing that, and I had left
Thomas Adler: you know, I had left the Bluegrass Music Museum. I was still involved in bluegrass. I kept playing in bands locally. I wrote a book-length history of Bill Monroe's Brown County Jamboree that the University of Illinois Press published.
Thomas Adler: in 2011, And, you know, Neil and others have…
Thomas Adler: have used that, you know, relied on the details in that for some later things, I'm happy to say. So, you know, I've kept my hand in both as a sometime performer on the banjo, but also as a… as a publishing author
Thomas Adler: at least about the limited things that I know about, and I still get asked about
Thomas Adler: Bean Blossom, which was the park, and the Brown County Jamboree, and
Thomas Adler: So I've tried to keep my hand in with, with the, Folklore and bluegrass.
Thomas Adler: and all that, and I actually have more time for that now that I'm no longer trying to do IT work for others.
Thomas Adler: all I have to do is, if I can do videos and websites for friends, that's what I do.
Thomas Adler: So that's where I am today, I think.
Thomas Adler: I don't know if that covers it all.
Julie Stout: Yeah, no, such an interesting combination of the tech IT world, and then your passion for bluegrass, and you're still able to, like, do education in some sort… some type of form as well.
Julie Stout: Are there… are you part of any, like, local organizations or anything involved in the community somehow, or…
Julie Stout: Anything?
Thomas Adler: No, no major organizations.
Julie Stout: Hmm.
Thomas Adler: No, I mean, th-there were…
Thomas Adler: different bluegrass clubs, but those were mostly just, you know, people that would get together and… and jam and play music together and things like that.
Thomas Adler: Nothing, nothing really formal.
Thomas Adler: Whoops.
Julie Stout: Oop.
Thomas Adler: I'm just getting a phone call, but I'll.
Julie Stout: No worries.
Thomas Adler: I'll hang it up.
Thomas Adler: Oh… My son calling.
Julie Stout: Oh, yeah.
Thomas Adler: later.
Julie Stout: back.
Julie Stout: Well, your son! I guess my next question would be, like, do you have a family? You have kids, I'm guessing?
Thomas Adler: I have two sons.
Thomas Adler: named Carter Adler, who lives in… near Akron, not in Akron, but near Akron, Ohio.
Thomas Adler: he's in financial services, and he's married. He has one daughter, actually married, had a daughter, and then he and his wife separated. He's remarried now, happily.
Thomas Adler: And so, we see Carter and his new wife, Amanda, and our daughter… his daughter, Rabea.
Thomas Adler: from time.
Julie Stout: Or a band.
Thomas Adler: Maya.
Thomas Adler: It's an interesting name. I think it's a Middle Eastern name, ultimately.
Julie Stout: Yeah.
Thomas Adler: They just picked it up somewhere they liked the sound of it.
Julie Stout: go!
Thomas Adler: We see, Carter and Amanda and Rebeha, but not as often as we'd like, since they live some hours' drive away.
Julie Stout: Yeah.
Thomas Adler: Locally, my younger son, Noah, is married to his wife, Stephanie, and… and they have a daughter.
Thomas Adler: Nell, and a young son named Arlo.
Julie Stout: Whoa!
Thomas Adler: And we see them quite a bit, and that was Noah just calling, so I'm gonna have to…
Thomas Adler: Bring this to an end and call him back pretty soon here.
Julie Stout: Of course, yes, as you should. Have you been able to pass down any bluegrass music to your kids in any way, or…
Thomas Adler: Not to Carter, but Noah is a REALLY great musician.
Julie Stout: Really?
Thomas Adler: He's… he's a wonderful… he was a top-notch French horn player in high school, made All-State band first-chair French horn for 4 years.
Julie Stout: Wow!
Thomas Adler: He abandoned that when he got onto string instruments, and he's an absolute top-notch mandolin player and singer, and we were in some bands together for a while. We were…
Thomas Adler: For a while, we were in a band that we called the Blue Eagle Band.
Julie Stout: The Blue Eagle Band.
Thomas Adler: That's, I can explain that in reference. I told you my mother's maiden name was Blau, which is…
Julie Stout: Well, yeah.
Thomas Adler: The name Adler in German means eagle.
Julie Stout: Blue…
Thomas Adler: Blue Eagle is Blau Adler.
Julie Stout: I love that.
Thomas Adler: So… so Noah was part of the Blue Eagle Band, along with a woman bass player here, and… and several different folks on guitar, and we played for a while. He's really dropped back out of that, because since his kids are young, he has to spend time, much more time now, raising his kids.
Julie Stout: How's course.
Thomas Adler: There is no Blue Eagle band right now, but I'm in two other groups at the moment, one called Liberty Road, and one called Farm Town.
Julie Stout: I… farmtown!
Julie Stout: I love that!
Thomas Adler: So, yeah, you know, I play music with these groups. Even when we don't have a paid gig, we get together and play anyway.
Julie Stout: Just jam out.
Thomas Adler: That's right, and perhaps.
Julie Stout: Yeah.
Thomas Adler: We want to have some songs ready in case we get a gig.
Julie Stout: No, of course, of course.
Thomas Adler: The end of the month, but, you know.
Julie Stout: Yeah.
Julie Stout: Do you have, intention to potentially pass it on to your grandkids as well?
Thomas Adler: Since no one's.
Julie Stout: 40 into it in some way, so…
Thomas Adler: Rebeha, up in Ohio, plays violin, but she's.
Julie Stout: So she's classically trained.
Thomas Adler: I think in… in playing by ear, you know, in…
Julie Stout: Yeah.
Thomas Adler: like that. She does play, you know, with youth orchestras up there, and so we see her… sometimes we get videos of her playing the violin in orchestras up there.
Thomas Adler: And it's too early to tell about Noah… Nell and Arlo, they're too young, but we'll see.
Julie Stout: That would be so cool to have, like, three generations playing together, that's why I asked, so…
Thomas Adler: It would be great, yeah.
Julie Stout: That'd be great. The last thing I had for you was, is there anything else you'd like to share, or talk about, or, discuss before we put this first interview to an end?
Thomas Adler: I can't think of any.
Julie Stout: You can't think of anything?
Thomas Adler: We've covered a lot here, but .
Julie Stout: Yeah! And so, that's great. I'll end this one here, and then.